oh Cake Defense yeah Cake Defense well I
thought the knife was a cake I didn't
think it would stab them
oh my God
hey townies welcome to another episode
of dumb people Town population years
population
James you're here we're happy I love
yeah I love the shop classes you're
wearing are phenomenal well people don't
know this there's a woodworking bench
over there
do you address this you know that it was
here and you just saw us flying around
come on hey on us in punch lines
Festival in Laguna finally honest
might be a record dead two seconds into
Johnny Carson can I just say that I was
walking down I was on Hollywood
Boulevard we were going to do a show at
The Bourbon Room and I looked down and
there's a star on the Walk of Fame for
Rich Little and I was like Rich Little
had a wonderful career thanks to Johnny
Carson and whatnot and I was like he was
a good and pray good impressionist I
think it was good I don't think he's in
the same league as James Adobe and I'm
like James and Domin should have a star
on the home and you know what the
difference is and James you're the
person who taught me this what's that
it's the difference between doing an
impression and comedically creating a
character that sounds like that person
that you infuse your comedy and your
take and your situations that elevate it
from Just and I've said this maybe here
I could go out on stage and just say and
Doug Benson and I for a really fun
reason built a gamer on it just say
lines from movies and it will crush
people holy [__] he did the thing but
then comedy is what is my angle on that
and that's why it's almost not even an
impression it's a character that sounds
like and you you were the person who
goes you the example you you go
Will Ferrell's Robert Goulet is a
character it is it's more his comedy and
character than it is impression and
that's why it's so great right it's
nothing it's like it's it's it's like
liminoly attached to the real coverage
but when you can really combine them
like you do where it sounds actually
exactly like that person
you're Bernie Sanders as imbued with
your comedy that's when it's like well
that's the fun thing about doing Bernie
was I got to say I got to say things
that I wanted to happen right because no
who cares it's my show it would be like
for far too long psilocybin mushrooms
have not only been illegal but vilify it
is time that we provide free shrooms to
college students
I think you should have to pay for the
head but the stems should be free
those specific things what percent of
the steps has Bernie ever seen your
impression oh yeah we we did a thing
together and he was he fine no he's
grumpy his wife his wife was in the room
she really liked it so I was like that's
all that matters to me right then he
said Bernie enjoy protecting his image I
think he's probably you know concerned
that he's On The Fringe anyway and he
wants to be mainstream as possible so
those are the people people are doing it
means you you've hit has Jesse Ventura
ever seen your Jesse yes and he I I
mentioned this in stand up occasionally
he uh he messaged me uh and you read it
exactly so he I sent him a video that I
had done as him and then he messaged me
and the type the subject of the letter
the the message the first line was all
caps
that's great and then he goes you got me
and then surprise surprise the next
thing was an ask he goes you want to
come on my podcast a hundred percent yes
yes yes and we tried to but it was turns
out it's difficult to arrange a taping
with someone who lives off the ground
yeah off the ground we went back and
forth I'm not available when are you
available I can't disclose that
information
we need to set a time Jesse Yeah and
then we were supposed to actually
finally do it because he was going to be
in La at the studio and then day before
he was like we have to push it there was
a fire in the building
you're like I believe you but that's so
weird they're trying to stop us they
don't they don't want this Summit to
happen the summit it's a summit it's a
summer Summit it's the Ted Turner Ted
dibia summer all over again it's the
summer of summit all right that's rich
little very funny but doesn't fully
embody he had comedy and he was funny
but I agree so I walked across that and
I literally thought of James don't mean
that you deserve a star in the Hollywood
Walk and we saw you in the world and we
said we miss you and come do this here
he is so Jay let's get into the story
I'll do Story number one because world
is still done what were you going to say
my generation doesn't become famous
that's that's there were fewer people
back in the 70s there's no room I'm not
gonna be in the Hollywood Star Walk of
Fame I'm gonna be in the Playa del Rey
so like sand walk so I would say this
until the tide comes in yes but if if
you had
if Bernie Sanders was a candidate Like
Walter Mondale in 80. if he was like a
legitimate candidate running for
president and Carson was on and they
found out that you did a Bernie Sandman
if they if the DNC hadn't made him an
illegitimate kid talking about uh you're
talking about Mondale here yeah no no
I'm talking about Sanders no we're
saying if if he had been a candidate in
80 running against Reagan oh my God and
you if you went on to Carson and did an
unbelievable thing and then they found
out you did other people there's four
you could have had that that yeah you
would have had that massive pop that
what you're saying right now doesn't
exist because there is no program you
can pop on and just yeah everybody's not
watching Carson right yeah there's no no
the eyeballs are all scrambled in
different directions we're scrambled and
we're dumber and then that's what we're
all about on this podcast so this was
sent in by Liz Hagerty at Liz Haggerty
hey Liz uh Travelodge lost and found
this is the mid-year
uh save for work version of what was
stuck in our bodies so this is the lost
and found at a Travel Lodge
what did people forget at a travel line
do you think they're very dignity
their child do you
I think even worse on purpose do you
think that they're building new travel
lodges Travelodge feels such a like they
stopped building them in 1964. and
they're either still up or not and we
can't find the font have you been to
Howard Johnson's all right here we go uh
today's Travelodge has a review if
you're lost in the woods when you get
down the hill out of the woods on that
Highway and you see a Travelodge you
know oh thank God that means there's a
better hotel nearby
that's their slogan actually I don't
know I've never even been doing they
might be great right Travelodge we've
housed more serial killers than you can
shake a stick at that's right uh
Travelodge has revealed some of the
interesting items left behind and it's
580 UK based hotels during the last 12.
Travelodge don't sit on our bedspread
with how many people Travelodge we won't
leave the light on for you for a good
reason but life doesn't work
Travelodge those bags are pretty strong
they can hold even body parts but they
have no brand identity they might be
great they might be great I don't even
know I don't know Travelodge our cups
aren't plastic I want to know what their
Masonic connections are it's a lodge for
travelers and and time travel
Travelodge we still have keys yeah you
know I'm sure they might I don't need a
key card reading all my information
there it is it goes all the way to the
top
Travelodge you can park right in front
of your room Travelodge we'll bury it
for you
Travelodge don't worry about the stains
um all right here we go how many people
annually stay at a Travelodge Hotel
across the length and breadth of the
United Kingdom United Kingdom annually
500 people
they have 580 hotels
I don't know any average person says
they're touching I'm going to say 250
000 people and that might be low
I'm gonna say 180 000.
um right
um I'm gonna say half quid okay
how about 19 million people what yeah
way low okay so detail below more than a
half Queen some other it's not a hotel
yeah
all right some of the uh unusual
treasure customers have forgotten to
take
keys to a sun Seeker Hawk Oh wait we're
going down the list now yeah okay so
this is the lost and found no you're
lost and found and just it is nobody
thought all these things were stuck up
in someone's anus yeah yeah well they
might show up at the end of this year
okay keys to a sun Seeker Hawk 38
powerboat whoa
that's not that why would you cheat a
hong bow which is a Chinese wedding
envelope containing how much Chinese
yawn oh like oh oh like the little gift
yes how much yawn they've got their own
Emoji yeah yes I would say
eighty thousand yawn a hundred thousand
uh God okay so yeah sure yeah it's a um
um 50 50 50k quid okay 10 000 Chinese
yawns it's still a lot I don't know five
generation family cookbook heirloom
that's sad dude family cookbook you know
that that's cursive writing you know
someone's husband is getting so much
[__] for them where's the cookbook
where'd you do it how long did you put
it on the Shelf five generations yeah
that's Jello molds and casseroles and
oxtail a live-size cut out of Jurgen
klopp who's the coach he's the coach of
Liverpool oh soccer oh okay hurricane
klopp sounds like a little golden book
character
save him save him I'm going I'm going
Freddie Mercury no Rance got you rand's
got you
uh it's great television yeah it is good
TV
I guess I should straight up play What's
it is that the answer
you can do whatever you want you guys I
don't know if you know what you're doing
okay I think I've done this at another
uh all things comedy I think I've done
the same thing with a different table a
Queen Elizabeth II platinum Jubilee doll
what yeah to an adult leave it leave it
they said leave it a Lego technique
Ferrari 488 GTE you put that together
and left it at the hotel this is Alan
Moore did are you ready for the saddest
one of all
of Christmas pres a sleigh full of
Christmas presents a Slave full of
Christmas presents hey old school
Christmas in the UK man come on a how
many people for Christmas
oh we forgot the sleigh
all right a how many foot Chinese temple
birdhouse
10 foot build a Chinese temple Birdhouse
in your soul mantlefish forever uh seven
feet uh it's a yeah but yeah yeah uh
it's a it's a 10 meters 10 meters that's
a 30 foot challenge uh get your answers
in it's a five foot China I was close
seven feet I just say I thought it was
plausible a disable Pro LED phototherapy
mask a box of personalized Viennese snow
globes oh personalized that's an oil
painting of Queen Elizabeth II who is
Trav
as touring comedians
how many times do you sweep the room
before you leave oh always I lost [__]
I've lost I have to usually lose the
most are bandanas and sunglasses I just
replaced these
um but yeah I'll use a straight cord or
something like that but like this is why
you make your hotel bad too because you
know something could get lost in the
shuffle blanket like I say make it but
like throw it out over and get out yeah
and I make it pile it up I look around I
like to strip it they don't that you
can't even go under like I'll still be
like let me just make sure nothing like
yeah the maid didn't steal it you forgot
I'll get all the way luggage is outside
of the room I tend to always keep my key
with me in case for some reason I have
to run back up there yep and uh I'll get
everything out of the room and then I'll
go I'm gonna go one more time I'm just
gonna go through and you pull back the
shower curtain look under the sink
there's our dead body this is my
favorite time of day by the way uh as a
frequent traveler is checkout time yeah
the clumbering of bags and like the door
closes and there's bags on either side
of a closed door that you don't have a
key to anymore yes
my favorite time of day that's cool but
I don't understand is the people who do
stress out who stand in line to go we're
leaving you don't have to check I just
want to tell anybody who may not know
this you don't have to check out just
leave you can throw your keys at the
front desk as you're walking out or
throw them away at TSA like I do like I
do every time you you just leave like
someone at a dinner party is like I'm
gonna go take a pee you're like okay and
there's a checkout line whatever you did
in that room you're like oh well they'll
charge you break some of the wine don't
worry they'll charge they'll charge you
for it my thought was that I was there
trying to like like
plausibly pretend that I was out at 11
A.M even though it's now like noon yeah
yeah and be like and be like yeah yeah I
just enjoyed some other facilities after
I checked out uh you know just a mere
formality to hand the kids I was in line
at 11. this line is crazy
the lion can't make you late uh are
these are items that were left behind in
a Travelodge an oxygen tank what I need
that you got it a pilot's license wait a
minute and then he took it off
uh a 50 year old Paddington Bear that's
sad that is a sad no that's an adult's
bear also that makes me want a 50 year
old Paddington Bear he's going great
he's starting to Sag a little bit around
his
pouches
like I don't care man do whatever I've
seen one train station
because I got sick of wearing it that's
why I don't have the Hat on okay I don't
even want the honey pot uh
and there never seems to rain he's sad
that it's not I don't even like me hat
uh a Barrister's wig and gown wait how
is he gonna do the show up to work and
like Bermuda shorts
this is all this is all one stay from
Benny Hill it was a Benny Hill sketch
yeah he was I had you he had to get out
of there fast so he left the Barrister
framed wedding vows from 1946. oh my God
that was their they got him after the
funeral where'd you guys get married at
a Travel Lodge probably a suitcase full
of Queen Elizabeth II platinum Jubilee
memorabilities
at gas stations like we have petrol
petrol filling stations and we have
NASCAR stuff in there we have like like
Tiger prints that you can buy
Queen Elizabeth
a forgetful chief executive sent his
assistant how many miles to walking
Central Travelodge to pick up his new
John personalized number license plate
which he accidentally left his hotel
room you're sending your you have a
personal assistant you're staying at the
Travel Lodge they might be nice I don't
know it might be nice look if it's a if
it's your license plate you do need it
247 miles 247 miles
uh well it's got to be yeah it's I'm
gonna say 310 kilometers I will go 100
kilometers it's in miles oh it is in
miles oh well the nevermind I'll convert
somebody to 100 yeah 100 miles 247. uh
okay yes so what is what did I give you
that's uh it's about 100 miles 100 miles
you guys both said all right well here
we go someone is very close 250 miles
thank you you sent your assistant for
okay so 247 I was three off yeah
shaquila Ahmed Travel Lodge spokeswoman
said with nearly uh we we said how many
customers are there uh thousands of
different reasons we get a range of
interesting items Left Behind during
2022 this included a portfolio of tattoo
artwork a three meter long long Wu
Chinese dragon wow an actual Dragon an
animal an animal
you're like where's my dragon how long
is it honey you've got the dragon three
meters nine feet so are you sure that
that's not a dragon that people carry
through the street it could be a paper
machine cardboard you wanted to be a
real dragon
one room that is a great [__] party a
replica it's uh it's Falcor I'm a luck
dragon there you go uh yeah they're
right a replica of Queen Elizabeth's
State Imperial Crown a pair of Segways
really they left him in the room a pair
of Segways well then they've guessed
that they just uh clumsily transitioned
between a few sentences
I believe in you Randy I don't why not
let him hold it
keep it anchored on the ground all right
here we go grounded ground we'll fix it
no I like him rolling this an LFC
wedding cake what LFC what does that
means Leeds football club London
fighting Meister leister what'd you say
and a pair of Japanese Chin puppies
called JLo and Ben Japanese Chin puppies
I gave her a Japanese Chin puppy and
check me out Japanese Chin public Style
a chat what is it Japanese by the way
that does sound like a phrase Tom likes
would use gave that woman an old job
family is Chip puppy if you or if you're
going to solve way or there's only one
way to get out and that's a Japanese or
it's his term for breasts let me see
those all these kid puppies
I told this woman
if she's a woman then she loves the big
baby wolf character
it isn't even a character I don't know
Japanese he's a real person and you're
barely characterizing him it's a one for
one almost like I bet he would see it
and he'd be like he's not going far
enough he doesn't like me he doesn't
like you he knows yeah
and then I don't have a sense of humor
he blocked me and then of course I don't
of course he did what are we gonna go
hang out right yeah no uh but one time I
saw him in LAX I swear to God it was I
was sunglasses the half percent sure it
was Tom Leykis because I had met him
once before when I was in college but uh
I was too embarrassed I wanted to be
like are you Tom likes but in like the
one and a half percent chance it wasn't
him I thought what a terrible insult old
man who's in bad health
where's your Jazzy
for people don't know that's part of the
gimmick with him that's all right okay
Japanese Chin puppies are taking us to
the break that's Story number one
Japanese TV case got Story number two
come back we'll find out how you can
support uh this wonderful man where you
can see us the three of us performing do
our things it's dumb people town with
James and Dominion don't go anywhere
hey guys welcome back to the show uh
yeah this was I mean look at the
beginning of the year we do stuff that
was found inside of us and this we just
did uh I was inside our travel you know
I call my anus the travel lunch Hey yo
uh it's an early checkout uh so uh James
James you can always check out everyone
you can never leave
hey uh stopping up uh Jay let's talk
about sorry it's Imodium uh Common Era
now comment is that what it is they
changed A.D that's smart thank God
that's really smart that's more
inclusive CE that's so funny all right
so Jane I uh we can tell you that this
is dropping I talked to Aaron that's
dropping on on August 1st hey happy
birthday to you in four days Daniel
thanks buddy happy birthday to your
daughter thank you on three days and so
Jay and I tonight will be at Largo we're
doing tag it where uh our friends do
their stand-up sets and Jason and I are
on the side just uh have you done tag it
with them yet uh what is the Improv so
no you come up do your set and then when
you get done they join you on stage and
give you all the funny tags
and then you just sort of it ends up
become a friend comedy like what happens
in a green room the audience gets
successful no I did did we do it at moon
tower yeah that's it oh my God it's so
fun so we're gonna do it at Largo I know
we have Pete Holmes on the show and
we're sort of working on other folks
it's such a good deal so it's got that
going on and then hey we're going to be
at the Huntington Beach rec room I
believe on the 12th on the 12th of uh
August and then we've got dates coming
up this fall and Ann Arbor for Fort
Collins uh Springfield Missouri all that
and then we just added uh Portland and
Seattle in January Portland on January
4th in Seattle on December 1st where are
we going oh somewhere cool are those
tickets on sale yeah first I think is
Cleveland Cleveland hilarities
I love hilarities we love this super
squash.com will put all of it on there
we love you guys we'll see you at all
those shows and who knows maybe we'll be
doing our uh two-man show that we did
last week at uh the dynasty typewriter
somewhere Off-Broadway you never know
Daniel where can people see it go to
danielvankirk.com to find out when my
monthly show that I do in Houston with
Andrew Youngblood is you can also be up
to date on Best Bet comedy which is my
show with Irene 2 that I do here in Los
Angeles every single month plus I'm
coming to uh Boston and Austin Texas but
the big Las Vegas and yeah a whole bunch
of other dates as well but the big one
is 11 11 23 it's a Saturday night
Chicago Illinois the Lincoln Lodge it's
my special taping and my next album
recording I would love it if everybody
came out to that I don't know if tickets
are on sale yet for that but you can
still put it in your calendar and tell
yourself take a wish come hang and I
imagine after the shows after that
second show I will find a bar in Chicago
I love that that you can order deep dish
pizza people can roll into that and tell
me that they like today so everything is
at Daniel van kirk.com Lincoln Lodge is
a fun place great great is montgiri
still doing it no I don't know yes
um how can people see you are you
touring around available for bookings uh
which is a building season uh this is a
regenerative uh season in the in the
team's history uh I am
gearing I'm coming from being flat on
the ground to gearing up to just a
Powerhouse momentum great I love that
we're doing a taping of a stand-up
special we're tired of taking no for an
answer I'm saying no to myself now okay
I'm I'm taping my own stand-up special
and rejecting it here in LA and I'm
rejecting my own stand-ups I decided to
take the power in my own hands Power of
Now sometimes the no is better than he
has I'm taping it I'm shopping it around
just to me and other adomians the answer
is going to be no and that's the answer
but we're taping it September 14th at
the Elysian theater I love that theater
it's a beautiful space and uh a bunch of
regional shows around California uh to
get get ready for that I'll be uh in uh
it's not quite booked yet but I'll be
around California in some different
places outside of La a lot of La shows
leading up to that and uh it's probably
going to be at the end of August in
Atlanta and a bunch of other
Southeastern uh cities near Atlanta
this is all coming together now so as of
August 1st uh try me on Instagram at Jay
adamian
j-a-d-o-m-i-a-n uh you can find me with
similar handles on Mastodon uh you can
find look me up on uh truth socials
I'm just kidding uh no I should get it
so nobody else does right yeah you
should I meant to say counter social
actions
um there is a website james.com defunct
let's see if I have it up and running uh
ahead of my odds get it up and running
my uh my special taping uh this is a
good fire underneath me let's go are you
promoing it now and gives me three weeks
to pull it together
jamesadomian.com maybe or maybe not
Elysian theater 914 for sure still not
purchasable as a special definitely okay
all right let's jump in another story
Dan one thing I forgot to tell people
yeah and I this is very important for
our townies any show of mine that you
come to on the road bring a dumb people
Town headline or a pen pals letter if
you know what that means Google it if
you don't but I love you townies I do a
part in my show where I come out and
just talk to you guys and you read me
ahead I love that and that's how I serve
the algorithm also join our patreon we
have great experts five bucks a month
easy you uh also if you're gonna go see
a Dan Van Kirk show live uh bring a tarp
bring a plastic tarp in the front row
died and I stepped in someone took over
someone it's me and his brother we're
currently in a meeting with the melody
here we go sent in by Dan Leone at
designer 1973. oh that's his aesthetic
or theirs also this story is just one of
those things
if we were walking through dumb people
town later on you go see her over there
she's the woman who blank okay we can't
wait an Ohio woman thinks Bigfoot has
returned to the Wilderness near her home
and she believes she has
audio proof of he didn't leave the woods
what do you think he was on he went to
College summer internship he did a gap
year he took us sabbatical this is the
first time I've ever recorded harl's
Suzanne faranakak said fairness
is not a real name it sounds like
Dorothy's a born ax neighbor
if I ever heard it
I know I'm probably saying it wrong but
I did what are those birds that keep
making that noise
they're so loud
that's very good God damn those fan
attacks get them out they wake me up the
two minute long recording keep listening
can't you already
Mike a boom mic out in the a little I
pictured one of you by this point Werner
heard song is like the Verner furnace
he's the only no one should ever listen
sometimes the only one who's like the
Rolling Stones watching Altamont yeah
they're like oh that's what happened
yeah that's it right
this is from the two minute long
recording which she shared with she
shared with the Mansfield News Journal
who I blame because they ran with it
this is from Mansfield News journal.com
story now which is part of the USA Today
Network because it's not that hard to
make the news no uh she says it captures
the sound of an unidentified creature
howling in the distance the dog a wolf
right coyote
hear and say or whatever fernacak who
says she has encountered Bigfoot in her
area before says it's a Bigfoot creature
how has she encountered him before
well we might we had a brief
relationship Believe It or Not other
Wildlife experts aren't so certain
believe it or not I don't believe that a
group of but they did say Wildlife
experts aren't so certain a group of
workers
I really wish it was scientists
at a nearby Mohican State Park suggested
the sound could have simply been an
alpha male coyote calling its package
exactly
I mean I could see this going both ways
you've got on one hand unidentified
sounds yes on the other hand an alpha
male that's right well Jesse the
conspiracy is going to get thicker for
you because yeah she plans to discuss
her encounters during Bigfoot base camp
weekend which is
which concludes on September 11th at
Pleasant Hill Lake Park what are the
connections there well that's the kind
of we knew we knew it we've seen the
documents going back decades I would say
this recording is an inside job fernica
says she first caught a glimpse of
Bigfoot when it allegedly jumped over a
back road southeast of Loudoun
loudounville Ohio in May of 2013. yeah
her description of the seven and a half
foot tall hairy beast matches those
commonly used to depict creatures known
as saswatch Yeti and grass man how do we
know it wasn't Harry from Harry and the
Hendersons oh that's the saddest ending
in your movie John Lithgow was chasing
get out of here don't you see we don't
want you here we come back like you
anymore don't you see you're not one of
us and you can't dance
wait grass man
have we ever heard that one do they call
it grass man I thought grass man with
Seth Rogen she describes commonly used
to defeat creatures
creatures known as Sasquatch Yeti and
grass man I've never heard grass I've
never heard grassland is the weed dealer
in 1971 right these are just street
names in Portland do you have a grass
man in Portland yes it's the grass man
she can lift on Yeti and then make a
right on Grassman and then you want to
see her you'll be inside furniture
oh God
got a giant foot I do like would you
call it big I would say uh this is a
woman who's never not on Facebook I
agree like she literally has that app
open on her phone she is also addicted
to the show is it cake my daughter loves
it it turns out she's pink loves is it
cake I've watched every goddamn episode
and I'm like why are we not do that for
you Ryan I'm like we have to be honest
every time I want to be on it no it's
hard to get on his occasion I want to be
an honor you guys could get up he's kind
of Predator was on is it cake and I love
Jake got a break too council do I
understand that your client is pleading
not guilty because he thought that the
victim was a cake yes
that by the way that is definitely gonna
happen Cake Defense yeah Cake Defense I
thought the knife was a kick I didn't
think it would stab them
oh my God
the other place
Mikey day is cake okay uh the shirt
she's wearing says the citizen science
Sasquatch inquiry that is so many
supposing themes this woman has so many
military vests her rural home just an
hour's drive from Columbus Ohio so many
things are about an hour's drive from
Columbia exactly there's also a prime
habitat for bigfoot she concluded her
research culminated in a movie
the back 80 which was released no in
2017. I guarantee you it's Amazon Prime
yes Dan what's it called the back 80 for
Brady I love that yeah I love that movie
that's why they try to get in through
the back door uh when I see this woman I
just want to ask her one question how's
the horde going right if you're gonna
get out of the back 80 you're gonna need
some Japanese Chin
I had a Japanese ship of it get out of
the back she reuses to go containers and
I don't have a problem with that but I'm
saying she does it she orders a drink
for the road for several years fahrenkak
and I am if you are hearing this
yeah you mean the basement yeah yeah for
several years Farren cack said there
were knocks and howls around her home
and sightings in the woods behind her
property then all the activity stopped
it was like well wow where did it go to
make sure she didn't miss documenting
any potential encounters she bought an
audio recorder for her backyard sure by
a trail cam nope nope audio recording
nope nope nope it's almost you somebody
said Memento earlier in a different
episode it is where
spoiler alert for the next 30 seconds he
realizes that he's caught this guy over
and over and over so he just wants to
forget to find a John G he doesn't want
his thing to come to an end I know you
only buy an audio recording when you
want if you don't want a certain level
of mystery yes for yourself plausible
and ignorant denial give yourself
exactly plausible doubt well to me it
sounded like it's not a very expensive
recorder that's also if you're gonna go
with a reporter
if I'm out I always bring for a sure yes
if I'm out I always have a recorder
going I've been doing this for how long
how long has she been doing the
recording if she only turns on when
she's out as though Bigfoot then
wouldn't be out and about
James Murphy on this but she checks the
tapes every night yes okay
um the cassette tapes I think they're
how long how many years has she been I'm
recording James so she's okay
she has nothing else going on no no
she's been recording for 11 years I'd
say seven years so this is like that
this American life that we listen to
where the father was thought his kid was
getting into like drugs and alcohol
because the grades went down so he
started secretly tapping the phone and
listening to their conversations so he
would have to listen to hours of just
song name teen phone conversations
trying to hear it and then found out no
then there was like a windstorm and the
panel peeled back a little and the Teen
figured out that the dad was doing it so
then the team started kept having
conversations but steering it away like
I've tried drugs but now I don't want to
do drugs anymore meanwhile he was doing
drugs it was a scam to scam the scammer
but what I'm saying it's like KGB CIA it
is we know we are being tapped we don't
need them down there on this lead right
but so what's crazy is the dad had to
sit there and listen to like hours of
teen that's what this woman has to do
yeah it's just like the conversation
Gene Hackman right in the conversation
yes she's just listening to hours of
whipperwills of just nothing right I'm
gonna say she's been doing this for six
years she's been doing this for
wow sure audio catalog now contains more
than 20 000 hours of teenagers talking
from her backyard in all that time I had
not recorded anything decent farrenkak
said that changed when something finally
broke its silence on July 3rd you know
mostly slowed it down yeah no it's
Bigfoot being like stop with the
fireworks yeah most evenings fair and
cack will hang out in a campsite area
she maintains near the woods behind her
home she takes friends there and will
build a campfire alone if nobody else
can make it that's a lot of campfires
alone yeah
she was at the campsite the first
weekend of July
if nobody can make it to the campfire
yeah what you're supposed to do is not
do the campfire and get sad and
depressed and have a beer by yourself
alone but in the yard or inside not
don't do the thing balloon yes you're
just meant to be alone and depressed hey
have a bad night abducted you're like an
in you're a buffet to an abductor well
she's at the campsite alone the first
weekend of July earlier that night there
had been a ton of fireworks local people
were blasting off fireworks in the
valley oh my God he really is gonna say
stop yeah said there were big booms now
you don't describe how fireworks work we
get it she kept stoking the fire the
Bigfoot broke the sound barrier
I would have just been flatulated
this new organization is doing by giving
her time
she's stoking the fire Saturday
became Sunday there then there was a
howl it was the third of July at 3 42
a.m suddenly she heard a howl then
another you hear some howls then you
hear a chorus of coyotes and then you
hear howls again that's a coyote I know
yeah coyote reaching out to other
coyotes she immediately thought it was
Bigfoot
foreign
Casey who's probably had enough of her
I'm already guessing Dan do you believe
in these UFO videos 100 you do well
they're yes they're unidentified flying
jobs do you think they're like
spaceships
the only thing you start there's
spaceships that always show up around
secret military Air Force Base well not
now this the only thing that I will that
it starts to get into is are there is it
like
beings from other planets in our solar
system or some people are saying
more plausible easier to get here I
would agree easier to full time than it
is to uh travel that commute from Alpha
Centauri you're exactly right amen this
that was a real Space Traffic James
highway from Albertson touring you're
gonna see some real space tests third
lane
Pluto a naturalist at nearby Mohican
State Park is that scientists
naturalist is that scientist or nudist
he's a scientist who doesn't wear
clothes in his back I'm genuinely asking
do you know naturalist is nudists
naturalist is like not it's below the
level of scientists it doesn't rise to
the level of scientists but it's like
it's like nurse practitioners
it's like the paralegal of scientists
Henry David Thoreau Enthusiast right
sauntering around in the woods so you
got a degree in naturalism no don't
believe in degrees you know I'm a Healer
Kyle Casey a naturalist at nearby I'm a
life coach State Park said he and other
colleagues listen to the audio recording
published by the Manfield News Journal
which is on them and compared it to
recordings of other animals this is like
how they got the Tyrannosaurus Roar in
Jurassic it's just a whole bunch of
animals an expert in or student of
Natural History without clothes the
closest thing that we believe it would
be is the call Randy scolar of an alpha
male coyote thank you you're the alpha
male Casey told USA Today it's a coyote
calling its back but Casey like end of
story end of story shut this [__] up
like it really it's like cutter down
well here's the only thing she needs
because Casey went on to say that the
match wasn't quite exact that's all she
needs all she needs just a Shadow of
Doubt either way now that fair neck
farrenkak believes Bigfoot has returned
to her Valley she plans to purchase a
more expensive audio recorder get a
video I know
she know Dan that video
also records audio I don't think she
understands that it's one or the other
someone needs to explain that to her not
as a conspiracy video get just basic
Buster Keaton era technology yeah she
doesn't understand both we can do
talkies now
um they'll give you a little teaser for
the last story it's just understand like
when you shoot a gun that it's gonna go
somewhere especially if you miss just
understand people should understand keep
that we always ask that if you shoot a
bullet in the sky it's going to come
down at some point it doesn't just get
lodged into a cloud all right just keep
that in mind all that is gonna happen on
the other side of the break James and
domain is with us we'll be right back
hey gang uh welcome back to the show I
got one more story I'm gonna take it
this is sent in by Patrick Joseph at
mcmopat hi hey buddy here's the headline
squirrel squirrel shooter arrested after
bullet breaks child's window this is
just every choice this person made why
are you shooting at squirrels people do
it there's squirrel season in Illinois
is right before deer season
um
um squirrels can be easily deterred in
my opinion uh if you're worried about
bird feeding and plants and stuff like
that also if you're gonna shoot it you
better [__] eat it you better eat it
that's my rule you better be on the show
alone
go back to there's a back to a crumpled
old recipes from a great grandma we pull
it out
yeah what kind of you ever tried box you
ever try squirrel pie I'm so good
and you know that's the only impression
I do you guys do great impressions the
impression I do that cracks my daughter
up is Chicago guy learning to dab for
the first time
so let me get this straight and you dab
it over an air like that very that's
pretty and then I damn it over there she
thinks that's the funniest thing is
funny it's a great Chris Farley
character
all right all right so uh in East Grand
Forks Minnesota a Minnesota man is
facing criminal charges because he was
shooting at a squirrel and a bullet went
through a child's bedroom window
you realize you have neighbors right
right you don't there's no shooting
range where they're like and then past
the shooting range like actually
immediately you don't know how far the
property lies is
I've seen this case many times look they
put minutes
Lake I've seen it happen you were the
governor I was the governor and not only
that I was the mayor of Brooklyn Park
he's Grand voice will you say they
arrested a man Sunday after his neighbor
reported some bullet holes in the
sighting of their home and a hole in the
window of their son's bedroom oh my God
that's scary the man told officers he
had been watching ball games on
television so I believe it's not a
sports fan yeah which which ball games
you know the ball team that I'm a big
fan of uh
anytime says I was watching ball games
on television that's when you look to
see if that it's like you could have
said the ball game I was watching the
ball game on television on The Simpsons
said multiplexer screens yeah look I
understand it's a hastily slap together
story but if it holds water I've gotta
drink out of the cup
uh television and noticed a squirrel on
his bird feeder Dan you're right
squirrel on the bird feeder according to
the police I can't believe that animal
who doesn't understand logic yeah that
animal that doesn't understand logic
he's going after the food I left out I
can't believe I don't get it you that's
not an idiot and you know he shouted
from his window that's not for you like
he'd understand it get off the goddamn
and then he started looking for the gun
where is my living room that's a damn
Van Kirk observation that's not for you
maybe that's why I loved it he wants
some all right that's not for you he
wants some all right he told officers he
shot a 22 caliber rifle from his bedroom
window at this world my guess is he
didn't even open the window just
shattered his own window from his as a
squirrel he believed he hit the animal
he told officers he had shot squirrels
at least six times over the past two
years because he considered it this is
where you kind of know the psychology
ready this is where he says this line
and you know exactly where he is okay
because he considered it quote War when
they got into his bird feeder so this
guy is now declaring Wars tell me you're
divorced you're not gonna see it the way
I see it I got these
these girls did come and waves they come
in paxter and hold invasion of these
damn squirrels some have grown squirrels
some of flying squirrels and let me tell
you these neighbors I feel for him I
didn't mean to shoot out the window but
they don't know how far back it goes
because I had new neighbors every six
months back 12 years there's gonna be
casualties in War that's yeah he's like
he's like you know what when the
squirrels come for their house they're
gonna want me yeah they're gonna want me
on that one be on that bird feeder yeah
what be on that Pro meat a window
breaker until you need that window
broken because the squirrels come for
you with their rabies first first the
squirrels came for my neighbors and I
didn't shoot anything and then they came
for my front lawn and still I didn't
shoot anything they got into his bird
feeder according to the door down this
to me is you want to know so he's
married that's a bird feeder so he's
married the man's wife said to him well
I told you oh wow he is married well I
told you this is in the story she's
always saying things like that she's
always going on look you know what she's
up she's upstairs we live in a big dumb
house she's upstairs on the fourth floor
you don't have kids
and she was only seven State took her
away she moved out she didn't really
move out she was she moved out there's
her own thing the man's charges
recklessly uh handling a dangerous
weapon a misdemeanor and a felony count
of discharging a firearm within the
municipality he faces up to how many
years in prison for doing he's not gonna
go to jail and what's the fine that may
be and we'll probably be cut in half I
would say he faces up to two years in
prison and the fine is 500 okay what do
you think he's charging firearm within
the municipality I think that Max is
like 10 years in prison with a two
thousand dollar fine Jay what do you
think six uh five year five years in
prison did you say five you said two two
five years in prison with a five
thousand dollar fine okay one of you got
the years in prison right and one of you
at the fine right do you wanna change
I'm gonna say five thousand dollar fine
ten years in prison okay yeah that's
what it is okay get your answers in
townies because
two years in prison five thousand
dollars
hey for a half
now we've and James has done such a good
job of portraying this man and giving
him a voice breathing light your Runner
I don't have a runner if I if I'm
deprived of two two years of my life's
work who's gonna provide for my family
we survive on squirrel me what is your
life's work again
I stuff them full of their squirrel
tails and we survive on a meet I got 500
lawsuits already I heard uh Mike I'm a
good man Mr Lindell I heard that you
were actually selling off some of your
factory equipment and an entire Factory
is that really happening we're selling
it all off all the Pillow Factory we're
selling we're putting everything away
the the cotton pressures we're good we
got we got pillowcase trucks we got
trucks with the pedal cases still in
them we got a couple of Care Bear sleeve
labors we're getting rid of them there's
a fire sale on the Care Bears you're
selling people they're not people in
their carriers come on no it's a bear
you're gonna come come on now Jason
Randy that's actually Randy uh wait so
uh so we're gonna get out of here on
this how old is let's call him your
pillow sure your pillow squirrel shooter
how old is he 74 years old
59. uh he's uh he's 62. one of you is
two years off oh he's 72 57.
he's 64. get your answer is in townies
James the domian go once he gets his
website rolling now we've lit a fire on
oh it's going to happen and that
Allegiant show has happened in
regardless 9 14 19 9 14 you're going to
be at the Elysian and on 11 11 you're
going to be in Chicago the Lincoln Lodge
watching two great tapings two great uh
specials that taste great together all
right here you go we're getting out of
here on this shot through the squirrel
feeder thought it was a war hit a
neighbor's bed his son's window cracked
it and all two years five thousand
dollars is
76 years old
what a fun time James we love having you
on the show and uh thank you Tony's join
our patreon uh go follow us on all
socials and oh [__] we had to get back
to work bye
[Music]